Hiya Sophie.
Wow, those are some nasty scratches in your paintwork!
Would you like a respray?
I'll get my mechanicals on it right away!
Go, go mechanicals!
Let's choose some paint to cover that scratch.
I'm sure we'll find something to match...
...unless you'd like to try something new?
We could find another color for you!
How about yellow?
What about red?
The blue looks amazing!
Green really suits you!
Purple looks nice!
Stripey?! I'm not sure about that!
You don't like any of the new colors, Sophie?
In that case, I've got one more idea.
How about this?
Back to your old color: pink!
There! All done!
That nasty scratch is gone and you look good as new!
Bye-bye Sophie!
Try not to get that paintwork scratched again!
But if you do, we'll be here to help put it right!